hey [ __ ] good titty crusher 1985 here
back at it again with another live
update thank you for tuning in today
let's get started first of all don't
take this video the wrong way I know
this is the kind of video where I'm
trying to explain my perspective on some
things and everyone just understands
what I'm saying the wrong way and it
just backfires and it's like why do I
even bother trying to make an update
video by being transparent with you guys
anyway are we good to go okay cool
I was sick about a week ago which I'm
sure you know from all the constant
mopping and self-pity that you've seen
on Twitter and here on YouTube
I'm very routine driven person I have
like a strict way I do videos every day
I wake up I exercise I go to the office
I do a male's prep the video we shoot
the video and then meetings and then I'm
home
now I don't have an office anymore and
now taking out of my routine I'm just
like well [ __ ] it I don't want to do any
of that [ __ ] anymore I guess what I'm
trying to say is that I'm tired of
trying so hard I think I've been in try
hard mode with with YouTube for since I
started I'm a very addictive personality
and I think for the past six or seven
years I've been addicted to YouTube 100%
but now that I was taken out of it for
seven days which has never happened
before because even if I'm sick I would
still record videos which I guess is my
point it's like I don't really want to
do that anymore if I'm sick I'm just
gonna be sick I'm not gonna force myself
to upload and this is not a mopey video
as like oh you to be so hard or I want
sympathy or some [ __ ] like that it's
more like I want to be honest I'm tired
of trying so [ __ ] hard I had problems
with my internet a few days ago and I
didn't know what to do and I couldn't
upload properly two years ago I would
have literally taken my laptop run out
at 4 a.m. trying to steal neighbor's
Wi-Fi I did that for two weeks it was a
[ __ ] nightmare but I was like I need
to upload videos otherwise the world
will end I'm tired of doing that don't
get but here's the point don't get me
wrong I'm not tired of making videos I'm
just tired of trying so [ __ ] hard I
want to have a more loose approach to it
and so if you know that it's changed in
the channel for the past couple days I'm
my approach to YouTube is to spin this
is what I want to make today like the
the player unknown video that I did
which a lot of you liked which i think
is pretty cool but can that be an
entertaining video probably 9 but I
really felt like playing the game so I
was like okay well I'm just gonna record
myself playing it and see what happens
now we took me seven hours to get that
game play so I guess I'm still [ __ ]
trying hard I guess I just disproved
everything I just said goddammit [ __ ] I
can't can make a simple update video I
guess what I'm trying to say is I don't
really care about the result as much
anymore I don't care about getting more
subscribers or views I actually I do
just kidding but not as much I still
really enjoy reading all the comments
every single day and that's really
what's gives me a kick to make videos
and I'm just focused more now on making
videos that I feel like making than ever
I just wanted to be honest and
transparent about how I'm feeling about
the process and I don't want you to take
like the wrong way like I'm I'm tired of
all of it and all that [ __ ] cuz that's
not that's not true from what I noticed
the comments have been really great to
be honest much better than they used to
be and not because you guys sympathize
for me or some [ __ ] I think you
generally enjoy the content I don't
[ __ ] know it's so hard to tell but
personally I find myself to be a lot
happier these these past days I'm so
less stressed I'm so less but it's easy
to get ticked out by YouTube and I find
myself to be a lot less of that lately I
really really enjoy being back here at
my old old office it feels much more
personal
to be here again it's it really just
feels like me alone again doing my own
thing and I think that's pretty cool
last but not least I want to announce a
green-screen competition we've done them
before link is in the description
download that video and do whatever you
want with it
edit in in a funny way of funny YouTube
video I will review the best ones you
guys can help vote for the best
submissions as well last one was [ __ ]
hilarious
I love seeing how creative you guys are
and it's something I see a lot more
lately as well I really feel a lot more
proud of my audience these days just
seeing how funny you guys are on Twitter
and like how creative you are with these
events I think it's really cool people
are definitely gonna misinterpret this
video but I hope you understand anyway
maybe when I'm coming from I've been
doing YouTube for 7 years and I guess
I'm really just tired of being in try
hard mode and my love for making videos
and all that [ __ ] it's still there I
still don't want to quit I don't want to
stop anything
I promise everyone is always in the
comments like wait he's he's gonna snap
any minute I know wait that's not the
case I promise
probably was a bit close for a while but
we're past that now we're past that
we're moving forward thank you for
watching this video and as always
sister Pfister I forgot Schubert's
emulator is getting a new update it's
basically SimCity the update it's really
cool it's my favorite update so far I
know huh Dead game but it's really fun
if you haven't checked it out in a while
I definitely recommend check it out now
there we have the egg update which
depicts links it's really cool and I
think you guys are really gonna like
this one so if you haven't played the
game in a while now it's a great time to
check it out that's another thing your
creations in that game are so [ __ ]
cool and creative as well I love the
community that is still playing tuber
and
yeah just check it out Lincoln in bio
buy my merch and also buy my merch thank
you